welcome to the David Pakman show I am
fairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in once again today for David
Pakman and today I wanted to start the
show with a little bit of good news
because most of the stuff we have to
discuss is either terrifying or
depressing so let's begin with something
positive and the positive comes in the
form of new poll numbers showing that
roughly 40% of expected voters for 2020
40% rate climate change as a top issue
not the top issue but 40 percent say
that they are strongly going to consider
a candidate stance on climate change
before casting a ballot in 2020 and that
is up 5 percent from the 2016 numbers
when only about 35% of the country said
that climate change was going to impact
their vote so those numbers are going up
they're going up slowly but they are up
and that is always a positive 40 percent
it's not even half I understand that but
that is encouraging finally we have at
least 40% of the country as a whole the
eligible voters as a whole who
understand that climate change is one of
the most important issues facing this
country today not any of these made-up
scenarios from politicians it's not the
threat of Iran it's not the threat of
people coming across the border it's an
actual real threat that scientists have
been warning us about for decades and
that is obviously climate change now the
numbers get a little bit skewed when you
break it down by party you have with the
Democrats you have about 76 percent say
that climate change is important to
their vote a little over 30 percent for
independence and then of course we're
hovering around 10 percent for
Republicans those numbers on the lower
end obviously not exactly what we want
to see but we can take a little bit of
time to be happy about the fact that hey
at least 10 percent of Republicans say
Klein
change is important and to be honest
that that 10 to 12 percent is actually
pretty good considering the fact that
conservative media routinely tells us
tells their audience that climate change
does not exist that it's some kind of
liberal hoax that the planets just in
one of those warming / cooling cycles
that happens all the time or that a
snowball in DC somehow disproves what
scientists have been saying for decades
so 10% may seem small but when you
consider the amount of misinformation
that the Wright absorbs on a daily basis
10% ain't that bad folks I think we
should be happy about that and here's
the another reason why we need to be
happy about these 40% as a whole numbers
and that is because this is an issue
that we still have time to fix nothing
is set in stone yet and that is one of
the big things that climate scientists
have been encouraging people to talk
about when they talk about climate
change we can't talk all gloom and doom
we're done the planets dead no they say
we have to remind people that there is
still time because if we do talk in
those terms of oh we've burned the
planet down nothing we can do then yeah
people lose hope and they stop caring
about it they just say okay well this is
what it is nothing I can do I'm not
gonna change my ways I'm not gonna call
for action we're doomed but that's not
the truth we have time we have plenty of
time to be perfectly honest with you
it's just that we have leaders in this
country and other leaders abroad who are
not doing enough and it is our job to
push them to do more and that is why the
40% number is so important because if we
act fast if we stay on top of this issue
we can do something about it we can
change the future but if we put another
climate change denier into the White
House if we put somebody in the White
House who's squarely in the pocket of
the fossil fuel industry then nothing's
gonna change and we're gonna lose
another four years on this very
important issue
we may not have four years to lose I
know at the end of last year we got the
report saying we had about 12 years
before we see the irreparable damages
from climate change but that's been six
months so we're at 11 and a half years
now get that number 12 out of your brain
we've lost six months we can make up for
it we have the technology cost of
renewable energy are now coming down
it's actually more affordable than
fossil fuels we need the infrastructure
in place so look for that in candidates
especially on the Democratic side
obviously in their climate plans because
without that renewable energy
infrastructure all the windmills all the
solar farms all of that isn't gonna mean
that much if we if we do not have a
viable delivery system now that's
another thing that a lot of people don't
seem to understand it's like ya just
switched to renewables we could have
done that and we could have built out
this infrastructure 10 years ago 15
years ago started building it out but
unfortunately that didn't happen so we
are behind the curve on this right we
have a lot of work to do
but those who are saying that the
technology simply doesn't exist or if
you listen to the president who tells
you that oh when the wind doesn't blow
and you're on wind power you don't watch
TV that night that's a lie battery
capacity is up delivery systems have
evolved and if we put them in place we
absolutely as a country could do this we
could have been a leader on this issue
of climate change and renewable energy
but instead we felt in the back of the
pack and we're now having to play
catch-up to all of the other countries
in the world who are meeting their
emissions reduction marks while the US
has blown way past ours but 40 percent
is a good number not as good as we would
like it but at this point you got to
take every little victory that you can
and 40 percent saying climate change is
going to influence their vote that is a
good number
today's program is sponsored in
hurt by our friends over at Loch Ness
crypto dot-com the team is based in
Boise Idaho and they've made their
mission to help just everyday people
navigate the world of cryptocurrency and
they've been doing it since 2012 they've
actually been teaching a course about
cryptocurrency at the Boise State
computer science department for years
and they've taken that curriculum and
sort of packed it into an easy to digest
course that's now available to anybody
who wants it called the cryptocurrency
starter kit and this is the type of
thing that crypto has really been
lacking and it's one of the reasons we
we maybe haven't seen adoption of
currencies like Bitcoin and others on a
larger scale normal people who are not
tech experts need a step-by-step guide
that's easy to understand about how they
can get involved with cryptocurrency in
a way that is sort of safe and
manageable and that's what the
cryptocurrency starter kit provides it's
a five part video series which includes
how to safely obtain cryptos where to
set up your accounts how to protect
those accounts from hackers importantly
how to move crypto into physical
hardware wallets and also how to just
prepare for the future of the space you
also get a free physical hardware wallet
it's sort of like a flash drive where
you can safely store your Bitcoin or
other Kryptos offline and you also get
one hour of one on one phone or Skype
mentoring with one of lochness Kryptos
experts they're the only company in the
crypto space that offers a service like
this and it all comes with the
cryptocurrency starter kit they have a
special offer specifically for the David
Pakman show audience if you click the
link under this video you'll get $200
off the cryptocurrency starter kit check
it out using the link down below